the Marvel series on Netflix Daredevils
and Jessica Jones has a new series
adding to it available for streaming
starting on September 30th called Luke
Cage and the man who plays the Harlem
drug kingpin Cornell cottonmouth Stokes
in that show is sitting right here and I
will stop talking about you as if you're
not here but I first want to mention
that my guest was also Emmy nominated
for an outstanding Guest Actor in a
Drama series house of cards he's played
Remy Danton for many years big fan of
your work my herschel Ali thank you for
being here thank you for having me and
I'm a fan of your work as well thank you
for saying that
yeah I appreciate that before we get to
Luke Cage and other sports of your other
aspects of your sports loving world you
are not going to be in season five of
house of cards
no I what in the world is that oh well
you know it's a big show and and there's
a lot of wonderful characters but I just
I just wanted to do more and be
challenged in different ways you're kind
of really diversify and just improve and
it's hard to do that when you're kind of
on the schedule for eight months out of
the year and then you have to find
something in Michael four-month window
pocket I'm sure so I just wanna I'm a
hungry actor and I've been at it a long
time and that show has kind of opened up
some doors for me and I just wanted to
be able to take advantage of him so it
means letting go of one thing to be able
to to kind of go for something look I
know that people thought I was nuts when
I left ESPN with NFL Network and go live
in a different part of the country I
totally get what you not not to compare
what I'm doing or do anything so but you
know it was announced that I wasn't you
know gonna be doing sports anymore so do
you know how they're gonna handle their
character just suddenly not being around
anymore
they kind of did handle it and I
actually thought well cuz you were
trying to get gas in your car no cuz
that's at the end of season four Jackie
and Remy are together in a car and sorry
if I'm spoiling it but if you haven't
watched it we have we have what's what's
our what's our spoiler rule here in the
Rich Eisen show for something that 24
hours
all right 48 if we're feeling really
okay about ourselves okay so you have 48
hours here to watch 13 episodes because
we're all watching yeah but um so at the
end they kind of they leave and I think
so it would be up to the audience the
kind of you know it's life is ongoing so
and that's when we that's when we no
longer see them but they've kind of
driven off into the Sun okay and and so
again cuz when he was been trying to get
out of politics in in some way and it
keeps it just kept getting pulled back
in but I think he was he was ready to
leave as well and then you get into like
what does the character have to continue
to offer the story I'd rather leave when
people still are affected by a character
then to stay and people no longer really
resonate with the character like you
kind of seen all that he kind of not
sure sure that's that's more in line
with what I would think well
congratulations on your Emmy nomination
thank for for your work on house of
cards and now we're excited to see Luke
Cage streaming on Netflix starting
September 30th before we get to that
though let's talk about your basketball
work now you you went to st. Mary's
you're from Oakland right now I'm from
I'm was born in Oakland raised in
Hayward which is the neighboring city
essentially and yeah just so was your
hoops con growing up who was a grow
knows Jordan like you know I'd tried to
pattern everything I did after Jordan
how so how'd you do that but I feel like
I was I was a better athlete than I was
a player like I couldn't jump out the
gym you know it was in dunk on you
mentioned Jason Kidd you just hit an
hour and this dunk contest together and
then or the area okay
we tied cuz I think I did more athletic
dunks but he would do more he was doing
more creative dunks where he was
throwing the ball off the wall and like
kind of passing it to himself and with
the interesting way not real stuff so
okay no for sure and we played on oh we
played on a AAU like AAU team together
okay played in I think was the John
Farrell tournament we played Marilyn and
the championship game together played
against him when he was at Cal and I was
at st. Mary's so what were you a
shooting guard what were you I was Ford
was he in high school was interesting
which a lot of kids do with in high
school is because of
their athleticism or size like was I
haven't grown since I was 14 so I've
been like 6 to support cuz I got stuck
in the Pope's butt in and so when I
started playing the summer leagues yeah
I was just playing point guard and kind
of a tweener
yeah and that's how I got my scholarship
but I really wasn't prepared to play
point guard and to guard in college you
know and in the demand and how you run a
team like really knowing how to run a
team yeah
AAU does not count No and so I I
struggled once I got to more offensively
in understanding the responsibilities of
being a leader on the floor from the
standpoint of being a point guard
because you so that's when you turn to
acting rehearsal is our home start point
no I had I had a difficult time but I
was always a really creative kid my
father was in musical theater so he was
on Broadway and whatnot and so it wasn't
something I ever tried to do to that
point but I it was it was in my
periphery
mm-hm and so once I was approached about
doing a play in college I was like well
you know I play basketball I can show up
after practice and do this ya little
thing real quick and I did it I didn't
even read the play I just kind of
learned my heart and kind of would show
up and do my little thing on stage real
quick and one thing kind of turned into
another I kind of began to to feel very
alive on stage and also began to kind of
see the value in performing like that
sure and in telling stories and
narratives and began to take it more
seriously and then next thing you know I
graduated and I was doing California
Shakespeare Festival and and got into
NYU for grad school and studied acting
and now you're you're in Luke Cage on
Netflix streaming September 30th my
herschel ollie here on the Rich Eisen
show so who's a scrappier st. Mary
player you were Matthew Dellavedova
scrappier you Dellavedova I would say
Dellavedova you have a dirty part of
your game no I think if I had been a
little bit dirtier I probably would have
had a little bit more success but we
always had like a we always kind of had
a Dellavedova there's something in the
character of the school I'm here in the
water they're like yeah like there's
always do we
always had guys who were when I was
there was a guy named Yvonne Dodie and
Yvonne was a walk-on from Bishop O'Dowd
high school that eventually got a
scholarship and Yvonne would do he was I
would put Yvonne up against Dellavedova
any day like in terms of just like hard
nastiness yeah really go down really
really go down on the floor down there
sure yeah
so Luke Cage starring you mike colter
rosario Dawson and alfre woodard they're
crying out loud yeah and this looks like
a bunch of fun on Netflix is just the
latest daredevil type or a Marvel type
series that's going down right now and
you play the bad guy oh yeah for lack of
a better term I play the bad guy I never
think bad people think that they're bad
mm-hmm but um yeah I do I do play the
villain and it's just just a wonderful
opportunity in a series that explores
like somebody being a superhero being a
reluctant superhero sure specifically in
Harlem and specific to his own powers
and abilities and and the threat that my
character kind of poses for for life in
Harlem for cause like the the tasks that
super that superheroes are kind of given
is to kind of create peace and keep
order and and so uh cottonmouth Cornell
cottonmouth Stokes is is a bit of a
handful for for location is there any
talk about Luke Cage Jessica Jones
daredevil may be doing some sort of
super Marvel show they're working on it
right now is called the defenders and so
III don't know when battle will arrive
but I know that they're they're about to
go on the production of that or there
might be doing it now and they're
they're doing the I think they're
shooting the The Punisher o'carroll as
well so they have a lot going on there
is the and they're really what's what's
great is that they have a different type
of license to to kind of explore story
and to make these little a little darker
and and more nuanced then say they can
on like a ABC or whatever which is more
of a primetime
network and they can they can do things
that an HBO can do on that flip well
congratulations on going from house of
cards to a Marvel series on Netflix you
just say going from one to another good
luck to you on getting that Emmy then
come back anytime thank you please thank
you please do that
mahuri lolly check out Luke Cage
streaming on Netflix starting September
30th the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience